uh
[Music]
[Applause]
the crimes that we had done
were they anything
at all
[Music]
the
anything
[Music]
a stranger
it is
[Music]
the lines that we had drawn
they got easier
to cross
sometimes the times are gone
did the feeling just get lost
[Music]
sometimes the times are gone
did the feeling just get blurred
to be a stranger
[Music]
it out
here
[Music]
it takes
is
here
it is
[Music]
hey so this was kind of a funky idea
where i just decided that i wanted to
spend a flow session making shapes with
my knees
um
yeah it just randomly came about one day
and i thought i could expand the idea
into an entire flow video so let me know
what you thought of this
big thanks to flotoys for giving me the
space to go out and experiment with
dance ideas like this
if you'd like to grab a set of those
spin 9 vision poi from flowtoys you can
do so by heading on over to flowtoys.com
and using my special promo code it just
changed it is now drex factor 2022
with no special characters at all in
drex factor we just changed it uh that
will get you a discount on your order
and it helps out the channel so
everybody wins uh thank you once again
to flotoys for sponsoring this video and
making it possible for me to go out and
do fun dance experiments like this and
speaking of thank yous a big thank you
is ode to the friends of the channel uh
big thanks to uh dark monk fire mecca um
flow fests flowtoys pyroterra light toys
juggling calling
spinballs and ultra poi for helping to
make the videos on this channel possible
um if you'd like to learn more about all
these amazing companies and the work
that they're doing to support flow
artists like yourself you can do so by
checking out the links that i've got
down in the description of this here
video and special thanks to the
non-business friends of the channel that
is johnny howard les muchinski and becca
beckham
thank you one and all for your wonderful
support for my work and my mission
final thank yous uh this video would not
be possible were it not for the support
of all of these amazing people right
here these are my flow patrons over on
patreon and they along with the people
listed down in the description help to
make this video and all the videos on
this channel possible thank you all so
much for your support from my work if
you're out there watching and you are
not currently a supporter and you would
like to become one you can do so by
heading on over to patreon.com
drexfactorpoi and signing up you can do
that either at the link in the
description or the card that just popped
up if you're watching on youtube there
you can get access to a whole host of
awesome rewards and even better you'll
be helping me out in my mission to bring
poi spinning and flow arts to the whole
wide world and helping people connect
with their bodies and their brains so go
check that out please and thank you
uh and thank you the viewer out there
for watching this video for checking out
my work and
if you would like to check out more
videos of me flowing and dancing with
variety of different props including
these spin nine vision poi i will leave
a link to a playlist of other videos
like this one down in the description or
up on screen if you happen to be
watching on youtube make sure you get
outside and flow today it's good for
your brain and your body and i will see
you with a new video next week thanks
and have a good one peace